erica is in Chicago hi Erica
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi can
you hear me okay I sure can how can I
help
awesome well I want to start off by just
saying thank you because because of you
about gonna say five years ago I'm
listening to you four years ago I became
that free so I got married two years ago
came in to the marriage obviously that
free life I said initially we're on the
same page to make the long story short I
ended up showing a civic that I had to
purchase two cars because my husband is
here from South America
so we bought two used cars one of them
works awesome the second one we
basically were told it had like 80,000
miles and I've had like 200,000 miles we
had obtained like five times more than
what it was and it died a couple of
months ago so now my husband wants to
finance a new car and as you can imagine
I am thinking out I don't know what to
do I don't wanna I don't want it to
become an argument but I don't know how
to convince him that that's just not a
good idea okay why are you convinced
it's not a good idea well because how
was your principles I don't want to go
invest one you know like I said why
because of the gold we have long-term I
mean we were almost we were pretty much
done with our emergency fund we wanted
to like supposed to buy a house the car
itself is going to lose so much value
why don't we take it out of the place
and listen I get it son
I feel like we could get another car at
use I feel we just had bad luck would be
the ones that you know think of the
toughest and when you say all of that to
him what does he say he says that it's
just a huge risk that we can probably
were probably going to get ripped off
again and if she doesn't want to do that
then we your car and why would you not
get ripped off if you bought a new car
trust me I've tried to say everything I
can't I just don't know like it even got
you so bad to a point where he's saying
that I'm just so close-minded
with the way that I think about money
that maybe we might maybe we shouldn't
go separate ways types of things or
we've gone too fast for me and I'm like
thinking of like the white side of me
trying to be a good Christian life is
like okay should I show is your
definition of a good Christian wife
going along with misbehavior um you just
you just use the phrase good Christian
wife in order to give yourself
permission to cave to a wrong decision
so that was going to be my question like
do I let him make a mistake and he'll
realize that it was at stake in the long
run or do I just put my foot down and
say no we're not doing this no well
here's the thing
hardhead that's your husband's name he
is unwilling to take his wife's input
that's a problem in a relationship you
shouldn't be running over him and he
shouldn't be running over you the Bible
says submit yourselves one to another
and if your husband is wanting to do
cocaine and he thinks that's a wonderful
thing are you a good Christian wife if
you go along with it
no and buying a car on a car payment is
financial cocaine it's stupid as a
matter of fact we know it's stupid and
it's not that you're not willing to bend
it's like I understand the law of
gravity I'm unwilling to jump off the
building I get it there's a law in force
here and I'm not a law breaker I'm not
jumping off the building I don't care if
you think you can fly I'm not jumping
off the building you know and that's all
you're saying is this is an illogical
bad decision it's an unwise decision
here's how we know it's unwise all the
things that you just said earlier when I
asked you why you didn't want to do it a
car payment keeps you from your goals a
car payment is financing a large asset
that goes down in value a car payment is
the signal you want to be middle-class
the rest of your life because all the
data points of millionaires tell us they
don't borrow money to buy cars and
haven't in several decades when I ask
millionaires what the biggest financial
mistake they ever made
they said we bought a new car on
payments one time when we were stupid
and that's then then we quit doing that
Stein of stuff and that's when we became
millionaires when we just studied 10,000
of them that's what they said as opposed
to hardhead in his opinion so what do
you do I don't know I don't know how you
deal with a hard head exactly except
possibly the - if he's threatening that
you need to go your separate ways
because you won't go along with
financing a car then that says that your
relationship comes down to him
controlling your decisions that ain't
much of a relationship and that says
that you need to be in marriage
counseling to me okay I think that's
what I need to hear yeah cuz hardhead is
you know he's pretty much gonna be his
way or the highway says what you're
saying you're gonna go along with my
stupidity and if you don't go along with
that I'm the man of the house then
you're not a good Christian wife and we
need to go our separate ways that's
what's that's what's floating in the air
in this conversation am I missing
something okay no and I think I need to
hear it that's what I was thinking as
well I was just not sure at what point
do I just I'm not suggesting you end
your marriage over a car payment but
this is really not about a car payment
this is about control okay this is about
who's going to control things and he's
gonna it's my way or the highway so
what's next if you go along with this
one what's the next thing you have to go
along with and the next thing you have
to go along with against wisdom see this
is not how a proper relationship
functions and so I can guarantee you
that if Sharon Ramsey pulls that same
kind of crap she and I are going
toe-to-toe and she can fight she's a
hillbilly woman she knows how to fight
and vice versa if I'm doing something
she you know that she doesn't go along
with we go toe to toe and we don't do it
very often we've been married a long
time we figured out how to not act that
way but we do not make major decisions
in our lives unless both of us are in
agreement there's some things that she
wants to do she goes and does them and
I'm okay with that and we talked about
that I have no desire to do that you
want to do that ahead off go do it
that's fine but it's not borrowing money
on a car it's you know who you're going
to lunch with or who you want to go to
dinner with or whatever I'm
I'm happy to not do that you head on and
that works out fine but major decisions
like buying a piece of real estate
making them a major charitable
contribution a decision like that if
both of us are not in agreement we just
don't do it until we have agreement
about it we do not move forward
proactively on financial and life
decisions of size and I've learned I
make a lot more money that way proverbs
31 says who can find a virtuous wife for
her worth is far above rubies the heart
of her husband's safely trusts her and
wait for the financial part here's what
it says and he will have no lack of gain
so men if you're married to a virtuous
woman and if you're married to a
virtuous woman usually she doesn't have
to tell you she's virtuous that's part
of being virtuous she doesn't think
she's the holy spirit that's part of
being virtuous but if you're married to
a virtuous woman that has an opinion you
will have no lack of gain when you go
along with that and that's not caving
and that's not being a wuss and that's
not not being a man that's not you know
being impact or whatever that's just
getting along in relationships properly
and listening to each other the preacher
said and now you are one and so if you
make decisions by yourself you're using
half your brain because together you're
one but one of you is a half and so
that's how this works and I've made a
lot of decisions with half my brain I
run the car off the road in the ditch
meanwhile my wife was going I think I
saw a bridge outside
I think I saw flashing lights here yeah
well well I'm driving the car okay right
not a good idea so we learned to work
together and we've had no lack of gain
ever since it slows us down it gets
unity in the household it creates
relationships by the way another issue
is when we stay these millionaires none
of them said I did this in spite of my
spouse
out of 10,000 millionaires
some were single some were divorced but
none of them said I have I built wealth
in spite of my spouse's bad decisions
never happened once it's always we work
together to hit our household goals we
sacrificed together to hit our household
goals a hundred percent of the time
that's what they said never said i
drugged the princess along kicking and
screaming never came up in the research
not once so low probability of prints
are hard head or princesses that won't
work together leading the wealth very
low probability